[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to channel
Awesome's orbit report your source for
everything happening around the world
and pop culture and entertainment news
i'm heather ruse and I'm Anna wave and
this is your news for Monday April 30th
first up this past week was CinemaCon
and there was a lot of new footage and
announcements that was made but we don't
know a lot about the trailers that were
shown obviously because we went there
they were made public cuz always these
reports we'll see them soon when I'm
assuming a lot of it too is I'm sure
testing the waters of like what
audiences want to see but it's a little
sneak peek I'm sure and you can go read
some descriptions if you feel very
strongly about it but some of the things
that was seen this week were some
footage from predator Halloween
Aquaman's Shazam and specifically one
that sounded very interesting to me was
the remake of Suspiria which is a body
horror and apparently people left the
screaming because it was just the sound
design was upsetting all the know all
the know hey man my curiosity though
always gets the best of me but there's a
lot of other things that happened but
first and foremost they announced two
new Star Trek films one that we don't
really know much about no title or
anything but the fourth Star Trek film
Star Trek four is going to get the first
female Star Trek film director which I'm
very pumped about it's going to be SJ
Clarkson she directed Jessica Jones
which is a nude black among other things
so she has some good things under her
belt and I'm very excited to see what
she can bring to the table the Star Trek
4 is also going to be written by JD
Payne and Patrick McKay
yeah and we don't really know too much
about them like you said we do know that
they're either
you prequels or having some time travel
involved there but nothing too much is
known about it yet also announced this
week in sci-fi we have more details
about a new Star Wars animated
television show coming to you on Disney
XD this fall and guys it sounds so good
I'm actually really excited about it
it's going to be called Star Wars
resistance and it takes place right
before the forced to live force awakens
yes it happens right before the force
awakens and it's going to follow a
resistance pilot who is on an operation
to kind of spy on the new growing first
order and we're gonna see some familiar
faces on it including bb-8 Po and phasma
and actually Oscar Isaac and Gwendoline
Christie are coming back to voice these
characters which is awesome I am so
excited to see more phasma I want so
much more phasma with her backstory so
I'm excited to see a lot more of her
though although they're not gonna be
regulars on this series but they are
gonna be appearing enough that they made
this announcement with it I do
appreciate that Star Wars kind of keeps
to their original casts of things and
brings them back for other things right
I like that Brady say that yeah another
really interesting thing about this is
it's going to be anime inspired because
they're planning on doing a lot of world
war ii or inspired dog fights with some
resistance pilots versus first-order
pilots and i think that style is gonna
work really well and as a style that the
creators have said they wanted to do for
a while with these types of animated TV
series it's gonna have a lot of the same
producers and writers as the Clone Wars
and rebels and those have been some good
shows so I really think that this could
be a solid production another solid Star
Wars animated TV series and again you
can catch that this fall on Disney XD
can't get enough of those oh so excited
Disney also this week announced a new
cast for the Kim Possible live-action
Disney original movie the newcomer say
DC
it's going to be playing Kim Possible
and Shan Gibran is going to be playing
Ron stoppable he was from the Goldbergs
yes I couldn't tell a lot of people have
issues with yeah maybe take it back a
notch she's 16 I understand that
hesitancy I know you're like nah I'm
still not sold on it now I know all
actors gotta start somewhere but this
was not just only her first movie but
it's her first audition that she ever
went on
although the casting my girl cared it
yeah I mean good luck it can have him
who the casting director did say that
she pretty much embodied the
intelligence and like physical strength
of Kim Possible so maybe it'll be good I
was just oh I'll be realistic with
myself
we gotta hyped it up in my head because
we have some of the original creators
and writers as a part of this project so
I thought maybe Disney Channel might put
some more money and power behind this
movie to maybe attract more people to
the Disney Channel get them to buy that
that cable service or whatever but I'm
not even sure I'd watch it now I don't
know fair enough it has some of it has
some of the original writers on it
though so that storyline is solid and if
the director is doing their job I mean
guess what it's gonna work
that's the most important part Sam I
still have hope but we will be also
playing on your nostalgia this week the
Nickelodeon gameshow double-dare is
officially coming back and I'm pretty
excited about it
double-dare was one of my favorite game
shows as a child although I don't know
legends of the Hidden Temple was up
there too I don't know which is better
let me know in the comments which you
think is better double dare legends of
the Hidden Temple I don't know but I
think this is a really smart move for
Nickelodeon I think it makes complete
sense to be doing this kind of game show
format um kids these days these days are
kind of used to seeing themselves on the
inner
and on TV and I think they could easily
get a good batch of contestants it might
even get really interesting if they did
things like take some younger youtubers
and had them like the teams against or
with their fans I think that might be an
interesting direction to take it in
there's lots of ways that this could go
really well I'm super hoping that
they're gonna keep the nostalgic 90s set
because it's kind of trendy right now oh
yeah yeah but my number one hope is Marc
summers we need you to come back please
please be the host of the show that's
all I want now I never saw the original
I didn't watch the Nickelodeon game
shows I'm sorry not all of it
I just didn't but it sounds interesting
and I would totally check it out that's
very good sounds pretty good and it's
coming this our two Nickelodeon sorry we
had to wait too much longer
another thing announced this week that's
playing into your childhood is Guillermo
del Toro is producing and co-writing a
scary stories to tell in the dark movie
which I think sounds amazing so many
things I'm excited for else because I
think if anyone could take that kind of
hone that those books set it would be
Guillermo del Toro those illustration us
and his oysters look like those
illustrations oh my gosh it would be
amazing and he's co-writing it with Dan
and Kevin Hagen who you might know from
this little thing called the lego movie
oh yeah um they also helped write some
of the troll hunters on Netflix series
as well as we're involved with Hotel
Transylvania so not only do these guys
know how to write some good children's
media but they have some experience in
children's horror yes so I think them
paired with Guillermo del Toro could
make a great movie with some really
interesting direction in town I would
also argue too though that all of them
know how to get things towards children
but also not dumb it down for children
and make it accessible to everyone so
that even the adults that are seeing it
are also really into it so definitely
hug for this so good I got the remake of
the
where they put them all together and
they took out the illustrations because
someone didn't understand what made them
so terrified
whatever last thing this week we wanted
to touch on it was that venom trailer
that we've all been waiting for because
we actually got to see venom this time
what a concept
oh my god uh his we are venom and the
wrapping around Eddie's head was really
scary and terrifying and he looks great
I gotta say I was so weary but it's
looking good yeah give me a little
glimmer of hope because that's right the
first teaser that we got I wasn't too
excited about it but maybe this could be
good I like that they kind of show him
arguing with himself yeah that's a good
thing to add in there for sure though
let's be real all of us nerds I mean by
oh come on weird but whatever ah it's a
choice it's a choice uh focus on that
instead of other things
see what you did there yeah one thing
that I will have to say it was it
reminded me so much of the trailer that
came out a couple weeks ago called
upgrade which was Logan Marshall green
which I and a few of other review
mistake for Tom Hardy often they have a
very similar look and there's a specific
fight sequence scene in that where his
body is fighting for him much like in
this trailer and I was like having an
out-of-body experience so weird how the
universe pero sometimes anyways I'm
looking forward to venom it looks like
there's still some hope left so decide
it for some more footage we'll see other
than that you can let us know what we
missed in the comments down below or
what you're looking for a test talking
about next week where you can hit us up
on social media
Heather is that for you you can find me
on Twitter at Heather Bruce Instagram at
a truce or twitch twitch.tv slash how
the roots and you can find me on
Facebook as I on await or everywhere
else as awesome Ayanna that's good be it
from us here we'll see you next week
same time same place in the meantime can
you be miss up
[Applause]
you